marketing for the now the marketing for
the now
marketing for the now marketing for the
now 10 minutes
12 remarkable guests for two hours
answering a sing singular important
question
[Music]
are you ready gary what do you think
hey everybody welcome to vaynerx
presents marketing for the now
gary how are you doing i'm quite well
andrea how are you
i am good i'm always excited for these
episodes but i think this one is going
to be a particularly juicy one
guess what we're going to talk about
innovation
all right let's go first up entertainer
tech entrepreneur and philanthropist
will
i am welcome
will it's good to be here thank you so
much oh what's good
gary it's so nice to see you i mean look
we only have 10 minutes
i've come to learn these go quickly so
knowing that every single person
knows exactly who you are i get to
actually go right into it which is
the question this uh month is where are
you trying to innovate
in 2021 before i let you answer that
you know we had i had such a great
pleasure of spending meaningful time
with you when we deplanted the apps
years ago
and i've always watched you from afar
and always knew
how uncomfortably creative you are um
and but but it's interesting you've
taken that
into a realm of innovation that doesn't
just sit in the arts
it kind of goes into the tech kind of
sphere so i'm dying
i'm like this is actually a fun one for
me because i literally have no idea
what's about to come out of your mouth
so let's get right into it what are you
trying to innovate in 2021 my man
um i'm trying to innovate on how i
work better with my team
and what we work on and how we work
right so covet 19 told us that
society is super fragile
our whole lives we thought that nothing
could stop the world
unitedly stop the world business stop
school stop like
what i never even thought that was
possible
so it changed the way we worked
now we're zooming and the phone is like
the center point to all of our like we
thought the phone was important
before cold the phone is like the most
important tool
in our life but you know is it the best
way to
work the tools that we have now is it
the best way for
musicians and different teams
like are the tools that we have
optimized for that like
were they made before colby thinking of
the way the world is now or is it
we just ran to tools that were already
available
um and now corporation they know that
you know
the world is probably never going to go
back the way it used to be we will
always
and continue to work from our homes
in our apartments from our cars
even when the world opens back up and so
i want to i really wanted
to participate in that in that space
and making awesome tools for folks will
when you think about that
do you you know it's funny i think
people are going to hear that and
they're going to go one of two ways
i actually think now that we've been
educated
on the sheer scale of online video and
capabilities
that this actually lends itself to a
better
work-life balance reality not the
reverse
i listen to a lot of friends who think
it's the other way
and i'm like no no you're in control in
a way that you know you're
you're succumbing to the way your
company is reacting right this second
take a bigger step back
go broader you know i know for me
you know uh my daughter having a
basketball game that i now can do the
meeting that's like so darn important
i think at a coffee shop across from the
gym that she's gonna play out that day
and not feel that anxiety of like
rushing out and being stuck in traffic
like there's so many hacks i can think
of
travel that i know i'm not gonna have to
do thoughts on
us being educated by this as a leading
indicator to better balance not the
reverse
thoughts yeah and i
um but i believe like another
tool is coming because i it's not
there's still pain points with the tools
that we have now
and and and more importantly like
there's inner city kids that are not a
part of that conversation
they're not a part of like there's inner
city kids right now dreaming to be
on james and that kid is like five seven
there's a kid that's five five right now
dreaming to be
jordan and and and the next lebron james
he's probably not going to do that but
he's still dreaming
he's still dreaming and practicing
because there's there's a lot of people
like him that come from where he comes
from that have made it
you know spud webb there's there's other
you know shorties that have made it
muggy bugs big shout out
mugsy bulks you know um there's some kid
right now
in the hood in the inner city dreaming
about being the next travis scott
they're dreaming about being the next
like dr dre and
kendrick lamar and that's awesome that's
freaking great
but there's not a kid in the inner city
there's not that many kids in this city
dreaming about being elon dreaming about
being
the developer that created you know
awesome tools at facebook
that there how do how do i how do i
innovate
to the point where it changes the
construct of what people from the hood
dream towards and raising money
raising money for a company that's that
turns out to be easier than raising
money
to educate people like raising money for
artificial intelligence
is easier than raising money for human
intelligence
let's talk about aiar vr just because i
know you're this kind of thinker
you know i love that you got to put
those last five sentences together
because i know what kind of sense of
responsibility
and kind of driver that is for you
because every time we get to hang
private public
it's huge when you see somebody that
does it that looks like you it just
changes
everything but for two seconds since i
got four minutes with you
and you're such a big thinker ai ar vr
overlay to what's going on with nft any
hot takes from any of those things i
just put down
so ai look at look at all companies that
boomed
um during coven they're all companies
that
are investing heavily in ar amazon
uh apple no they're heavy companies that
are
investing heavily in ai amazon apple
facebook google so salesforce so what
does that mean
that means they have so much money to
expand
their research and build awesome ai
tools
so what is ai and vr or ai and ar what
does that
mean that means you're going to be in
these environments in 2030
that you're going to work in these
spaces
you're going to and there and ai's going
to render a lot of jobs
obsolete but if you're if you're an uber
driver maybe in 2030 you're not an
uber driver right if you're if you're a
a deliver if you're delivering you know
packages
you're probably not that many package
deliverers in uh
2030 but there's going to be so many
jobs that we
can't even imagine 100 and where is that
coming from
well real quick just because i apologize
to stop your flow i just want to make
sure
people are following is your is yours
when you say 2030 are you saying
self-driving cars
and drone innovations gives you the
intuition
to say hey nine years from now shit's
gonna change
yo yo nine years from now you know about
the coal mining jobs that people were
like
are still hurting to bring back the
conversation we're gonna be having in
2030
is like yo my truck driving job my
delivery driving job my uber drop
there's going to be
so much noise around the displacement of
of of human jobs because i don't think
people realize how many people are in
the transportation
job market you
yeah it's like it's a huge market and
it's about to get like
dude like trust so what does that mean
right what does that mean like i i've
been do
i've had my school in the ghetto that
i'm from in boyle heights for
11 years teaching our kids robotics
computer science
and and getting them on track to go to
college we have a gofundme
um campaign right now it's gofundme
backslash
i am angel and i am angel because we got
we got one minute here we got to keep it
tight so slash i am angel right
keep going and the reason and the reason
why we're doing that is to make sure
that
kids can fill jobs not only that but be
a part of the conversation
to create jobs so so tying up like
what i want to innovate i want to
innovate the aspirations coming out of
inner city kids not only innovate like
that's a big that's a big hoop dream
but putting in the work mentoring
bringing folks from like bone we have
mentors that come from boeing to mentor
our kids from nasa to mentor our kids i
got a kid going to brown
uh dartmouth i gotta keep going to uh
georgetown
stanford like i started with 65 kids now
i have 1200 kids
well i appreciate your creativity your
innovation but most of all
your humanity i love you bro we'll talk
soon love you soon
next we welcome ukanwa ojo cmo of prime
video and amazon studios
she's responsible for leading global
brand and originals marketing
she's held top leadership roles at mac
cosmetics
cody covergirl unilever record bank sir
general mills and mead west vaco and ojo
has been recognized
with over 50 awards and honors welcome
ojo
that was a wild list that was like that
made me feel small that was
you've been killing it in a lot of
buildings whatever
i'm saying you crushed it with will i am
i can go
listen to you guys for 10 more minutes
i'm good i'm good i got my value for the
day
you know it's funny i first of all thank
you so much for being on
me and i rarely talk in the green room
because i'm like trying to milk every
minute i'm like
one until that eight nine seven you know
seven six five four countdown
i don't go but when i was so glad you
were in there because i had to tell
you that literally mrs maisel is my
favorite show
it's like like when we were putting this
together and i'm like oh she's going to
be on
i can't wait to tell her i got to tell
you in the green room it's the first
thing i'm starting with but really quick
why don't you give everybody a little
context um uh
maybe 30 seconds on you and 30 seconds
on the roll you're holding now and the
things you're thinking about
and then i'll set up the question okay
so i'm sorry one last point
uh team if we could throw this up let's
keep this conversation going on twitter
because i'm reading that as well so
maybe i can ask jojo a question for you
marketing for the now uh your thoughts
or ideas or questions
maybe the team can throw that up if you
guys can build that out georgie but go
ahead
no i was like first of all i'm so glad
amazing is your favorite show because
it's my favorite show so i'm like we're
we're in good company here um i love
mazel and it's actually in production
right now so it's very exciting
um so yeah i head up marketing for
amazon studios which is where we develop
our originals as well as prime video
which is
um the streamer and the distributor it's
kind of cool i feel like i have
two marketing jobs i have one that we
talk primarily to creators
and they partner with us to do all our
amazing shows um
and then obviously the other job is
direct to consumers who are watching all
the amazing shows that we create as well
as we acquire
um from other folks and we distribute
for other folks on our streaming
platform so
it's really cool to see the creator side
of it and the consumer side of it as
well
what has been the what has been the
biggest
surprise or cool insight
to go into a company that is this
progressive and doing something within
the company
that you know it's funny it's a tech
company you know this is very
creative by nature has some different
dynamics this is brand equity in a lot
of ways like
i you know i understand those dynamics
what are the
challenges interest what were you
surprised by
yeah what was exactly the way you
thought give us a little insight because
it is such a special company
yeah no so um one of the things that um
surprised me about amazon versus a lot
of different companies
is that when i saw the leadership
principles and the values ahead of time
you think that's just something you read
before the interview
process like it's not really a thing and
then you join and you realize like
no no no like it is the thing it's
religion like it's religion like
every decision is made that way we hire
that way
we develop that way we make decisions
decision investment decisions that we
acquire content that way it drives our
innovation our pipeline like everything
um so that for me is like oh wow like
being part of an organization that like
literally believes every word that it is
built on and like
everything we do is based off of that um
i've really enjoyed that
i've also really enjoyed that um they've
been more parallels than i expected
um because if you're really passionate
about consumers if you're really
passionate about earning attention
you can take that to a lot of different
industries so kind of coming into beauty
like
um coming from beauty getting people to
be excited about your great innovation
like you had to stand out you had to be
really interesting you had to earn the
right for the attention
and it's the same with the show like how
do i get you to watch coming to america
like
a lot of the ways that we're gonna do
that over the next week they're
they're not that different than you
would in other industries i think we
maybe lean in
to it a little bit more in entertainment
you also have you also have maybe more
ammo
when you've got eddie you know you got
you've got some ammo there to get people
excited i don't want you
i'm so excited to talk to you i'm
forgetting what i'm supposed to do here
so let me
let me stand it up what are you trying
to innovate
this year oh my god um so
i would say first of all is content
content is
where we have to innovate to win the
shows themselves or show
the shows themselves what about the what
about the content you put out to get
people to consider
to me that from afar as a fan you know
is what i'm obsessed with
the kind of content that gets people to
consider i know but that's
but that's the thing that's the whole
amazon thing the product comes first
like we believe that if we make the
product amazing
the marketing is so much easier and so
we're sweating like
the magic the content and we know
as hard as the life is right now like
people are
escaping to us and so we owe it to them
to really give them the respite to
really give them entertainment because
that's what they came to us for so we're
we sweat the small stuff on all of that
and making sure that we have
shows like the boys and william was like
i love the boys and you're like i love
maisel like that we have to deliver that
first and foremost
and then the second is yes in the
marketing um
from a marketing point of view um ask
you a question on that i'm sorry
is that decision making on programming
still internally based on talented
humans making subjective calls to the
best their ability and their careers
or given that you are who you are versus
let's say the way i would think about it
historically that abc
cbs would do it when i grew up is there
some
real heavy math overlays to lead you
into a direction of decision
yeah we do both we believe in the math
and the magic
so we um we'll do we leverage ai
we leverage you know traditional
research methods and then
we leverage our intuition and we're like
does this make me feel something like
what does it make me feel am i laughing
crying
angry if it doesn't make me feel
something um then i don't believe that
other people will too and we don't
we don't discount that um and our
emotions
and if we don't feel the magic we we
won't let it out the door
on magic and math on magic and math
any specific that you can share around
innovating in either department
um it's it's i would say we're
innovating on both
we're innovate because we want to make
sure that we're investing um
amazon really cares about the math and
so as i think
exposing other humans to the content
that we're making it has to be
we're going to make efficient
investments we're going to make sure
that we're getting the right return
for our dollars and we're very fortunate
actually that we have
the amazon platform amazon.com and a lot
of and we have twitch and we have a lot
of
different platforms that we can leverage
and we have our internal data that shows
how efficient they are to reach
you know people all over the world so
that's great but then on the second side
because we are entertainment
you don't get to succeed in
entertainment without earning attention
either from the content itself or how
you market so
if you think of the way that we marketed
you know borat where we had
you know or um like floating across the
thames
um in london and a lot of people really
captured that or
um him doing you know a lot of
interesting
twitch collaborations with influencers
and things like that like
there are a lot of different ways that
we have to earn the right for the
consumers to engage with us and make
them laugh and make them cry and make
them feel something
um but at the end of the day it's amazon
and and it has
it has to work and it has to impact the
business um for us to
just sustainably do it long term as a
human
who i respect quite a bit from afar what
innovation has hit you the human
have you seen any innovation last six to
12 months that you're like man that was
so awesome
no friction or i cannot believe the
packaging that this was delivered in or
anything random in any shape or form of
your life or your family's life or
through the eyes because you are who you
are probably amongst your friends and
families
have you heard of a story where somebody
was hit with some innovation during this
last year that they couldn't believe in
you were like mom or
cousin or friend how do you not know
that anything anything
around that innovation since we have one
minute yeah it's great um i would say
the innovation that i am
absolutely loving right now and i feel
like is desperate for my life is food
delivery
one of these for some reason it never
crossed my mind to order
breakfast at home and now and now i'm
like i feel like i get room service
breakfast
anytime i want and i am like that's such
a crazy
you were you at home for breakfast in
the past so you would do like a shotgun
breakfast and go to the office you
wouldn't do it in the office
well i'm talking like weekends because i
always okay
it's like after you've had a really hard
week like on a started
saturday morning it's become part of my
ritual good for you
order breakfast and i just never did
that in the past and so to know that i
can do that and like minutes later like
i have my omelette i don't have to leave
my bed
like it's pretty amazing um so yes i
know that's pretty trivial but that's
one that i just discovered during the
pandemic and it's literally changed my
life i'm obsessed
i know how busy you are these 10 minutes
meant a lot to us thank you
this is fun thank you
next we welcome greg lyons cmo pepsi
co beverages north america where he
leads pepsico's 22
billion dollar beverage portfolio in the
us greg has been with pepsico for over
20 years
launching more than 2 billion dollars in
new innovation
including life water and bubbly and most
recently driftwell
mountain dew amp game fuel and bolt 24.
he's also a data junkie building new
in-house capabilities
including a tool to measure and adjust
pepsico's media and spend
real time welcome greg thanks
hey ma'am hey man how are you good good
to see you
appreciate you uh greg and i've been
able to work together as vayner has a
relationship with pepsico so this is a
dear friend
so i'm going to go into my dear friend
moment first greg can i buy that pepsi
tray in the background there the wooden
one from you
it's really yeah okay i'll get you one
then
is it a real one or is it a rep no it's
a real one
respect your your background is very
nice i like it
i just um i have a new family now i got
uh engaged and brady bunched it
and so we just moved into a house which
we love but it's straight from the 1980s
as you can see
i think it's awesome yeah we'll have to
update a little bit greg let's go right
into it
what are you trying to innovate
in 2021 hey uh i'll answer that question
in 20 seconds
first i just wanted to give you a proper
shout out publicly
um thank you for all that you do for our
business
uh your terrific partner thank you for
all you do for the industry
um you keep pushing us man and you're
making us better mostly in the right
direction i think and then
um the biggest thank you is all the
positivity
positivity you're breathing into the
world right now all four of my kids
follow you
and uh they're they're they're better
off for doing that so i appreciate you
man thank you for all you do
all right thank you so much now to uh to
answer your question
yeah we're innovating a lot that's one
of the things i love about marketing is
it continues to evolve
and so i feel like it's it's very hard
to get stale
if you've been in marketing for your
career um the the places i'm spending
most of my time right now gary
are innovating or obviously we do a lot
of product innovation
um the way we do product innovations
evolving i can get into that
um both how we come up with the ideas
the insights but then how we get them to
market
we're innovating a lot on our creative
how we break through right now
as the media landscape is changing and
how do we make sure that our brands have
the right
are not tone deaf but also are
creatively special and breakthrough
and then most of my time on spending
right now trying to figure out how do
you
how do you innovate on how do you lead
these days
um and how do you make sure that
in this craziness and this unprecedented
times
um you know that you're leading with
empathy and transparency and flexibility
it's more important than ever before so
we're innovating in lots of different
places happy to get into any of those
um actually i'll get to one of them but
a lot of people i'm seeing a lot of the
comments talking about
wanting to become a cmo get into the
marketing game so i want to go into
early greg life that might be able to
connect these two
what was the first thing you saw in your
career that was
innovative that you recall really
shifted you like
you're two years in your your a weekend
you're five years into your career it
was like the biggest innovation
and it hit you and then it did play out
it was like wow i
wow that was wild oh my god six years
later
com was this or amazon was that or our
delivery truck or the way we make the
product was there anything that happened
in your career
i um the first thing that came to my
mind is
i don't know if this is answering your
question or not but
it's a real interesting concept so it's
um
one of the best product innovations that
we've ever launched
um at pepsico and it's such a simple
idea
which is called tostitos scoops
no i'm sorry to interrupt i want
everybody to listen here i'll tell you
why
what i think i have a lot of
entrepreneurs
watch this show this show no question
out of all my content is much more
geared toward the fortune 500 the wall
street
it is that kind of show with vayner x
being involved it's not me
gary this innovation i actually think
can hit a ton of people right now that
are shrinking and playing around
and could help them start a
direct-to-consumer business that changes
their life so
this is a huge home run this is even
better than i thought go ahead greg
so it's such a simple idea which is we
knew that people were dipping tostitos
right
and but what would happen is sometimes
the chip would break or sometimes it
wouldn't fit into the jar
and you wouldn't get the right amount of
salsa on it so you get salsa over one
piece but then you'd eat the rest and so
what a simple beautiful
idea to create a little scoop out of the
tortilla chips so you get just the right
amount of salsa
and then you can also use it for
appetizers and stuff like that and so
um you know when we came up with the
idea
it was so obvious and so big
that um but it got rejected at first it
was like oh we've tried that before and
you know it doesn't really work and so
then
you know it just took a little bit of
pushing it took one little shift
uh from one r d person and one you know
plant
operations person to say well hold on a
second what if we took the corn masa and
then we had these little implanters and
you put a little bump on what happened
with the scoops is unfortunately
when you cook the the corn um it gets
oil in it
and then you'd have oily scoops running
down the line
and some genius put a little bump into
the conveyor belt so the oil
went out and turned it over and
then by the way by the way just got to
give this shout out to brittany dickey
her hashtag scoop there it is it's
making me smile
the comments are as entertaining as the
content pleaser but yeah
so the best just the lesson from this is
the best ideas are simple right and
they're solving something that's a real
pain point for consumers or just making
something a little bit better
and what a simple idea that is and then
we figured out how to do it and then
it's you know it's
well over a billion dollars right now
let's talk about the r d part because i
think that will interest people because
they might get excited because we're all
consumers probably
uh well we all are uh on how you're
innovating
products yeah as much as you're allowed
to share what what can you get into
yeah so we use um uh a lot of data
right now and so um we
and we use ai as well um so we listen to
and this sounds a little creepy but
we uh we monitor what people are talking
about on social media yet
not any individual but in aggregate and
we understand what ingredients are
trending
and what um you know what
what people are making at home and what
people are talking about
um and the the ai part's interesting
because it it's really smart it connects
different things and so one example of
that is
um energy drinks in the last year the
the need
for energy the reason why people are
running energy is a little bit different
it used to be like i kind of hit a lull
in the day and i needed to pick me up to
keep me going both mentally and
physically
right now people are more stressed out
than they've ever been
and they need energy the energy that
they need
is to help de-stress so they can get
their mind
focused on getting things done and it's
not
always this pick me up because um
i i need a boost and so we took that
insight
and really quickly created a drink
that actually helps you de-stress and
then get some sleep it's called
driftwell
um that we just launched uh on amazon
which our friend was just on
and um and so this is you know
we used uh it was a simple insight but
it sparked a thought of like hey gosh if
we could have drinks that help de-stress
you
we need that more than ever right now
and you know in the past what we did
would we
be reading these big annual reports all
these trends
now like right now we just know what's
happening then it spits it
out and it does need a human being to
put it together and come up with the
idea based on the insight but
it it's so much better now so much
faster
greg the from an innovation from a
talent standpoint another thing that
might help some people
the info may get to you faster but is
there a retraining
or a culture shift that big companies
have to do to be fast
after they have that because a lot of
times that also the human
can kind of too many t's too many eyes
thoughts on that
yeah well the thought is you're exactly
right um the data is great
we got to be careful these days of we
used to
lots of people call it data driven
marketing we call it data informed
market yeah i like that we want to make
sure
that the data is used we had all this
data that we weren't using so we figured
out how to do that
but it does need you know some common
sense on the end of it because sometimes
the data
is garbage that you're looking at so you
need some common sense and then you need
a real
sense of urgency because speed
is so important right now in business
and
uh driving that culture of getting
things done
and getting things done quickly is
something that we're working on at
pepsico and we've gotten much better
this driftwell thing that i just talked
about
that was from idea to launch in about
six months
normally it was taken us two three years
from there and so
it's absolutely a skill that's critical
these days greg thanks for your time
brother
hey good to see you bud take it easy
appreciate it appreciate you
next up we have lyanna guzman the cmo at
skillshare where she's responsible for
full funnel right down to sales liana
spent four years at blockchain
most recently as the company's ceo where
she grew its user base 10 times to over
40 million
lyanna is an award-winning
philanthropist and claims that she may
be the only country music loving
mean rice and bean making francophile
leona i like that that was really good
thank you very much
it's a real pleasure same here thanks
for having me
um is that snow by the way before we get
into this it is we escaped our brooklyn
apartment for connecticut and
it has been snowing here for weeks
you had a great strategy over it now
like the
this puerto rican gonna be loved snow
until about last week and then
i move on gotta get done
uh first of all thank you for being here
second of all i'd love to get right into
the question
so from your perspective in the
organization's perspective where
where are you all trying to innovate in
2021
yeah so you know i would say on a macro
level um you know our mission is to
inspire discovery through creativity
and a big part of that is redefining
what it means to be creative and who it
applies to
right so i think oftentimes when you
think about creativity you think
did i study art in college do i love to
paint and are my paintings good and
a lot of what we're focused on in 2021
and for the coming years is around
you know shifting the mindset you know
much like nike did with athletes you
know what nike's perspective was if you
have a body you're an athlete
our perspective is if you held a crayon
as a child you are creative
right and um and i think it's really
important to us because we have seen
firsthand time and time again that you
know
exploring creativity really yields a lot
of the same benefits that things like
meditation do it's a really restorative
practice
um and you know to bring it full circle
when you give your brain that space
to explore things that are maybe um new
to you
or where you're really tapping into a
different part of your brain it gives
you the opportunity to come to your day
job and be more innovative there right
and so
for us it's you know i can't think of
anything more important in this day and
age in this
world that we're living in than
restorative practices that make us
feel more fulfilled and better able to
answer the call of today's challenges
and i think
that that's really where we're focusing
i love that
when did innovation really hit your
career when did you
get affected by innovation for the first
time or even if you want to take it
earlier that before your cr when did
you say oh technology oh new ideas oh
the world just changed in front of my
eyes what am i going to do about this or
wow i can't believe how much i'm
affected by this
yeah i mean it's been my whole career so
i think you know i
i'm gonna date myself here but i started
marketing right as facebook was coming
to be before they had figured out
advertising right so
i started in the very traditional event
based out of home
tv advert you know direct mail
advertising
and then over the course of you know
that first decade of my career by the
time i left it was all about performance
marketing and growth marketing and
and i remember being kind of the lone
voice in a lot of room saying i think we
swung the pendulum
way too far in that direction um and i'm
grateful that i've stuck around long
enough to see it kind of come back
towards
the real sorry are in math art and math
magic exactly like like you know amazon
the amazon you know it's that
combination that that art and science
coming together and so
um so i would say you know the first
decade of my career was defined by
innovation that resulted from the
industry changing
more in a decade than i think it had the
prior you know 50 years
um i would say the second part of my
career was spent at blockchain which by
definition was innovation right i joined
um
when in fact when i interviewed for the
job they reached out three times i kept
turning them down
and i actually called bitcoin unicorn
monopoly money i mean
that's where we were in the in the world
around cryptocurrencies
very few people knew who it was you know
what it was
and so it got my job was to innovate by
definition my job was to figure out how
do you make it
when when was that so i joined in 2016.
right i mean i i bought bitcoin in 14
and ethereum and 16
and did it out of
for learning not because i knew i just
knew i wanted to be
close-ish and really only in the last
year did nft emerge
in a way that like really speaks to my
soul
collector psychology social currency
uh i the nft thing is really interesting
to me
yeah it's an interesting space i mean
it's an and talk about innovating
you know i always say about that space
the benefit of the internet was that the
internet wasn't around to foretell the
coming of the internet
which is really important because the
internet had time to grow up before it
was prime time and so
you know i was in a space where
everybody was saying this is dead on
arrival and it's like no no no
no this is we are where email was in the
70s like
give it time you know and i think that's
what you're saying you know even from
when i joined in 2016
where it was you know nobody really knew
what to make of it it was for criminals
and you start having conversations where
you go well actually american cash is
the best thing for criminals
that's the most untraceable most
exchangeable currency right and so
yeah so i think by definition that whole
time in my life was completely
about innovation and then i stepped into
skillshare and it you know and it's all
about how do we shift the way people
think about it
what matters to them talk to me about
innovating
the art the magic i really like the way
you've set up
this context for the audience and so i
i'm just like being selfish right now
i have i think i have some similarities
to you as i've been listening
i grew up in an environment where the
website i launched for my dad's liquor
store was
needed to drive sales for me to even
have a seat at the table because sasha
vaynerchuk would have kicked me out of
the family business
but i always knew that one day i was
going to leave because i kind of knew
what my mission was help my parents
build their thing
then go do my thing i wanted to do that
for them
so i thought a lot about brand because
i'm like one day i'm gonna leave
and if i can build a huge brand around
wine library it's why i did wine library
tv
the day you you know the year youtube
came out because i was like if i can
build this brand
when i leave it will be able to retain
more of the monies because that's what
brand does
where do you talk to me about innovating
innovating
um on on art yeah you know because i
think you're
you're you know what i hear when i hear
your career i'm like ooh this is gonna
be an interesting question i wonder what
she does
to make the art the magic a little mathy
how do you get away with that because
that you know where i'm going with this
yeah that's a great question
so i'm going to give you a very quick
anecdote from my childhood so
ap english when i was in high school and
i remember every friday we were
practicing for the ap test first friday
we did it
mrs um fuchi was set sat us down and
said okay you've got an hour to do this
essay
we all started furiously writing the
second friday we came in and she said
you're gonna write the essay we still
have the same
60 minutes you were all going to spend
the first 30 minutes outlining the essay
and then the next 30 minutes rating and
none of us the first week by the way had
finished the essay
so we were all sitting there going how
are you going to give us half the time
to write and expect us to be able to
finish it
every single person in the class
finished the essay and that lesson has
left has stayed with me
um forever more because it is all about
having the preparation that gives you
the space then
to take this to take the big bets to
take the you know to
to bring it all together and so that's
how we approach it so when i think about
what happened last year
i think skillshare you know we grew
tremendously and i think it's because we
had laid really clear foundations around
what is our brand who what do we stand
for what do we believe
who do we stand for what do they get out
of us right when we had clarity for that
oh sure events shut down that's okay we
can pivot quickly because we know the
core of who we are we just got to figure
out how to get that message to you
separately
and so to answer your question i think
it's partially about the upfront work
that i think
folks don't take the time to do because
they're afraid you know
to your you know your dad's example like
we need to get some sales for sasha we
got to sell some of that you know
those liquor bottles and so we can't
take two months to figure out
what our positioning is and how we're
gonna stand well actually if you take
those however long it is and it doesn't
have to be two months for the record we
you know launched a new brand and
new visual identity came together in a
week so it can be done quickly and you
can innovate do you think real
real quick on that front do you think
that comes down to pat the ability to
make a decision and have conviction
when i hear what you just said i'm like
ooh whoever you whoever
was you know had the power to say so and
is an operator that comes from a place
of conviction i'm blown away
by people spending months on something
that's subjective
same and i think they do it because they
don't have the thing to point to
so if you have that here's what we stand
for
it was easy to say our color is going to
be wander green it fits right into
or more important than destination we
care more about the path
you know inspiring discovery through
creativity that becomes easy now you
know
now that's where the math and science
comes in it's also a really great
digital color
that stands out that you know separates
us from the pack so there are certainly
some
science parts of it some logistical
elements to it but it just comes
it gets easier because you have all the
foundation so i think that's part of it
and then the other part of it
to the mathy part is you gotta you gotta
be willing to take some risks
and you gotta do them incrementally so
you know i didn't join skillshare and do
a super bowl ad i joined skillshare and
did
programmatic at you know connected tv
and you know it's like you move up and
up and up
and you learn from those things so that
the next time it's better and it's
better
and also so that if you flop completely
one you can point to why it was a good
thing to do because again it relates
back to
those decisions you made about what you
stand for and then two
you know you're you didn't lose your
shirt and you you
you earned a really important lesson and
that was worth every penny you spent on
it because you didn't spend more than
you could afford to spend
you know so i think that's the way that
i think about it
i think you think about it really really
well i really appreciate this short time
coming from you team plea andrew can you
please get us connected
i need to be best friends with this
woman can't wait thank you
thanks next up we have umesh sripad
the chief digital officer at ikea usa
who is expert in product management
technology and consumer marketing
he leads the brand's digital
transformation creating a seamless
omni-channel
customer experience that delivers home
furnishing inspiration
through bricks and clicks previously he
led
global product marketing data user
experience
and engineering teams at organizations
including cnn
weather channel and overstock.com
welcome you mesh
thank you thank you how you doing guys
i'm well you mesh how are you
i'm very well thank you good um
what's the uh let me play a little bit
here mix up the format a little bit
what's the most interesting
innovative thing that's happened to you
during covid you know listen to your
background
you know you know i feel like technology
is something that's close to you
so i think your observation on this
question is interesting to me
which is what caught your attention of
like oh they're doing that well and then
we'll get into what you're
trying to innovate at ikea um
i think i think covert sort of put a lot
of us into
uncomfortable areas right um and also
they've also
talked about me stepping into ikea so i
came into ikea
in in in march uh or april of 2020 right
before joining so during during during
right
the company had already been worked from
home right uh
no it's the day after that i joined we
made a decision that we're gonna be
we're gonna be fully working from home
uh talk about the science right so
um you know pre uh joining ikea we all
have this impression in our head saying
that all right i'm gonna go there
you should have set up these foundation
in your head saying this is the basics i
understand the organization a little bit
and i understand the ethos and values
that this organization is made of and
all right i'm going to start with this
step
this step and this step and this step
and all of a sudden this comes up kobet
heads us straight in the face and we go
all right crush that plant throw it away
and and let's start off fresh
um there's sort of two observations that
i'll say that
uh when we sort of uh look into this uh
new era where there's no
a lot of information or data to rely on
it sort of creates their curiosity and
and it creates the creative juice to go
inside you
and and um you know it's the
process of evolution as well when human
beings are tested and
and when our backs are up against the
wall you know that's when we innovate
and i think the transformation and the
efforts that if you had asked me or
anyone in ikea
before um saying that hey
will you look at you know 10 months 11
months down the road that
you would have transformed your entire
fulfillment
organization and and enabling
click and collect and click and deliver
to happen in such an instant
instant pace or your complete customer
service organization to be transformed
and now be
working from home you don't even need to
come to offices to actually pick up the
phone calls for customers
i would be like no way you know we're
all joking at that point but
that's what we're able to do like you
know when there is a true
um opportunity in front of us and and
customers are saying that this is what
we need to do
i think innovation becomes easier and
that's the motive that we can actually
drive towards
and so to the point of the question uh
what
what are you trying to most innovate on
um innovation and transformation it's
sort of like the two buzzwords that that
sort of floats around
and is it is it is it i'm sorry to
interrupt is it a
strategy that you need to lay out or do
you think it's a cultural
shift inside of a retail company that is
auditing current casting and elevating
uh is it having those real tough
conversations around really what it
takes to actually innovate something
this big
um i would say that if if government did
not happen
then then it's the culture building and
and and um having those hard
conversations is what we would be
uh doing internally and covert has shown
us the uh the true potential that's out
there for digital uh
and how customers are sort of getting
into the the digital platform and it's
becoming a natural behavior
and and through the last 10 months i
think that cultural conversation or the
tough conversations that we need to have
it sort of alleviated a little bit and
sort of softened that can i ask you a
very important question just to mix it
up a little bit
do you think strawberries are overrated
or underrated
for me it's overrated because you don't
like them i i do like them but but
not my favorite fruits your favorite
fruit is uh oranges
respect keep going cheers um so so from
an innovation perspective like getting
getting back to the
uh uh the conversation so that's what i
said the two buzzwords are innovation
and transformation it goes hand in hand
so
the couple of anecdotes that i'll say um
around
uh that concept is until now we've seen
innovation sort of set the trend
for the retail i think covert has proven
us that the the trend or the consumer
trend is going to lead to the innovation
now
and then the second biggest opportunity
that we have now
is the brand loyalty is up for grabs
because consumers have have hit several
dbc providers
now and and and got used to the services
and experience that that
they're getting accustomed to and big
players like
us and several other people we need to
catch up
and we need to innovate in that space
so that we can grab on to the customer
loyalty side
do you think that organization is the
organization in your opinion
i was really happy to hear that because
i would you know i kind of always root
for the person that i'm in the interview
with is the organization self-aware
enough to realize
that that is a huge vulnerability and
it's incredibly important
to start storytelling and creating
consideration in a very very
i mean i'm such a fan of retail because
i grew up with it the innovation ikea is
is like something i admire at the
highest level
i'm also which seems crazy a progressive
marketer i think i'm a practical
marketer
and i think a ton of companies are just
stuck in 1986
do you feel the organization starting to
have that conversation
absolutely our research has proven us
and we're having this difficult
conversation saying that
the loyalty is up for grabs and and it's
our
responsibility it's our duty to actually
go after that and pretty much convince
our customers to come and shop
with us so that's what i was saying the
three areas that we need to look at is
how do we broaden
our visibility to consumers and and get
go after the masses and try to see how
we can convince them to come to ikea
and offer the right experiences and
services because they both go hand in
hand
and biggest of all the other areas
internal culture
yes we've started on a great journey
here because of culver
the internal culture has changed and
we've become more agile less
rigid and and it's it's just the
beginning i think i think we need to
continue on that acceleration path and
focus towards that
uh greater culture where we can embrace
the agility
early in your career which innovation
most shook you
like completely like
made me go bald um made you look go
handsome you're looking good
honestly like you know for me i always
talk about being a dorm room in 95.
koo kooch and i'm like what is this is
this the information superhighway
and just within an hour was like my life
is different and probably the reason i'm
bringing that up is
i'm shook by nft that there's a
technology that speaks to every part of
my bone story telling ip
collecting trading artistic like
you know just like on the like i can't
believe it social currency reputation
access community like i'm like this is
my moment that's why i'm
rambling so much about it the last
couple months after several months
of research how about you what
technology innovation
shook you i'm gonna go all the way back
to 2007
2008 you know my first journey this is
back in new zealand you know that's
where i began my career
a young product manager jumping into a
transformation
we all know that the mobile shook the
entire industry the first industry to
actually go through the transformation
in newspaper which is the print media to
the digital media
i think um i was beginning my career and
and mobile phones comes out that is your
iphone 3g
or or or the early 3gs and fours that
came out
sitting somewhere in new zealand where
there's four and a half million people
developing a product uh where you need
to transform your entire
uh newspaper into the digital platform
without a lot of experience from a ux
perspective and how to design a mobile
or an ipad app
and and start developing a content
management system that can actually
build and if we getting into the geeky
site
truly developing json frameworks and and
pushing the data into the front-end
aspect
and launching it for the mobile phones
being the first in the market
i think it's the adrenal kick it was the
adrenal kick
that um you know sort of set me in this
trajectory of saying that
the future is to which the uh uh digital
media
and sort of excelling there mesh thank
you so much for being on the show
pleasure to be here talk to you soon
andrea i snuck 30 seconds because i'm
going to do a contest in the comments
we're talking about innovating just what
is that gary
this is a burger i want people to guess
in the comments
from what company is this burger from
does it have strawberries in it gary it
does not but i'm ready for the next
guest
all right everybody can figure out the
burger all right next we welcome
renata ferrariolo vp of marketing
renata joined essie johnson in brazil in
1997
and she has been a globetrotter as she
took on leadership roles in marketing
and in sales in brazil switzerland
netherlands and the usa
she is revered as an award-winning
result-driven
people person with over 23 years of
global epidemic experience
living true to her purpose please
welcome renata
renata how are you good how are you nice
to see you
thank you for having me it's always good
to see you i'm blown away i think we got
a winner
i think this is right hold on one second
reality check
was the first one to say mr beastberger
they are correct
hit me up on email renate it's so great
to see you i adore your vision as a
marketer
let's let's talk about innovation as
as you go into this year as just a
progressive marketer
as a as a you know i know a little bit
about you right you've got
some youngsters around you your family
that are progressive
you've had this incredible career what
are the innovations that are most
interesting to you what are you paying
attention to and break it down two ways
one from the sense of like a fortune 500
executive thinking big companies which
are different
and one is just like you because i think
you're good at it
stuff that's just on your mind yeah
absolutely
but first i have to say like greg you
know you you know i have
my family is a big big fan of you i'm a
big fan of your company and i guess if
i'm progressive i've been learning a lot
from what you've been doing and some key
partners that you have as well and
and my kids are big followers of us and
car traders um right now i love it
so um let me i mean a couple of things
will sound obvious
but remember i'm coming from the cpg
world right the cpg world
um right now low medium growth
categories right
so to have this in mind with some of the
things that i'm going to talk about
the first thing i would say um from the
cpg world this
partnership with um growing extra
growing fast um social media um
companies
so i would say for example tick tock
right i don't think the cpgs have
cracked the code on tech talk yet so
this partnership with tiktok i think
it's it's one
great example of where cpgs should be
innovating
um especially on content creation and
how to partner with tick tock
and influencers of tech talk and people
that know how to do tick-tock
cpgs are still trying to create the
content themselves
still trying to put a lot of rules and
and guard rails around it
you know and and one of the major
objectives that we normally have in cpgs
is to grow household penetration right
and it's super explain household
penetration and
when you do that because i want people
to know uh everybody who's debating who
is the first person to say
mr beastberger we will go back look at
the film and i'll reach out to the
actual first person so don't worry i
know there's a
it's a brouhaha in the comments but
break break break down household
penetration
because a lot of people here are hearing
that but i don't think they know what it
is and actually tell everybody what cbg
stands for
because i see that question as well so
yes absolutely so household penetration
we're trying to get
to reach a larger number of consumers
we're trying to reach the
larger number of houses so it's it's
it's a metric it's a kpi it's a
an objective that we have in consumer
product good companies which are the cpg
companies
so we're trying to get our products in
more consumers house
so while we've been doing that for many
many years
the growth is is slow and then when i
look at tick-tock numbers for example
tick-tock took 19 days to reach 50
million people
television took 13 years telephone took
75 years
so for me if i'm in the low growth
category and i'm trying to reach more
households and i have a tick tock of the
world growing
at 19 days reaching 50 million house i
have to partner with
those big social um media companies that
are growing really fast
and right now i have to tell you i'm
very very intrigued with clubhouse
my house is coming really really fast
um and you know i'm there already i know
you're there as well
um and and it's a global uh platform
that is very intrigued on how can we use
that in the future to monetize
um and actually to be frank even to
engage with consumers uh and learn from
consumers in the
in the clubhouse space what was the
biggest innovation
that you saw early in your career that
made you understand
that an innovation can come along and
disrupt everything that you've learned
how you were trained how you were
educated each
you know i'm excited for your story but
like the stories that excite me is like
i knew how to do it and then this thing
happened and oh my god
i had to adjust i'm curious i feel like
people
that have gotten to the levels that
you've gotten to in their careers
have had to be comfortable with that
otherwise they would have stayed behind
anything do you remember your first big
moment with innovation like oh my god or
you believed in it
your seniors didn't then it became true
and you were happy that you were right
anything like that
yeah totally i mean i you know i'm gonna
date myself here but that's okay right
so
um it used to be so easy to see a media
plan and it was tv
outdoor radio um yeah and
i things right print yeah and now we
have three seconds to deliver our
message
so that was the biggest aha for me and
there was a lot of people pushing back
on that
um and and and putting brand uh and we
had a chat the other day about that
brand at minute one you know brent has
to be a minute three
second through his third second i should
say you know should be there right away
and um and i think people didn't see
that coming that fast and i think
a lot of cpgs waited too long to engage
um and and and
actually to to drive uh towards that so
i i think that was the biggest shift you
know you have all this time to
uh deliver you think on that front i'm
sorry i threw up you think because i
know a lot of different people are
watching
do you think that the agencies what a
lot of people don't know is that there's
five or six big holding companies that
own most agencies
it's a little bit of a uniqueness with
vaynermedia big shout out to widening
kennedy also
horizon media with bill there's a bigger
players that are independent but for the
most part
the biggest companies in the world work
with the biggest three or four holding
companies
do you think that the agencies have been
slow to innovate
and that's why brands are doing not
doing it or do you think it's the
reverse
or what what's your intuition on that i
think there has been a lot of resistance
on both sides
you know and we need more marketers um
like
need i have to say and some of my
friends that are really pushing and
really pushing for that innovation
and and as you said inside the company
but also with the agencies right it was
very comfortable to be where it was
but if you don't change you know it's
like commerce right if you don't change
now that won't be
a business for some of those companies
in 10 years so
i think agencies and also internal
old-fashioned marketers as well
as a mother yes up to
what was the innovation that you were
most against
as your kids were growing up that you
now have a different relationship with
because i think all of us as parents
will have one or two of those
historically
incorrect because we fear because we
just love them so much
that's an easy one video games
relationship
of love and hate right
it's a it's an amazing for the kids they
are obsessed about that
um they spend time doing that you know
some of the video games are very
um um scary to me that you know lots of
guns and
and and and blood and all that but at
the same time i changed my mind
after kovit been the way
so just i'm sorry just a recent change a
recent one it's kind of fine here in my
house but
during covet video games are allowing my
kids to connect with their friends all
over the world
we've moved a lot also as i was saying
so video game also allows them to be
connected to everybody um that they know
from all the moves and all the changes
we've had
so i've started changing my perception
on video game with that
because you know they they they can keep
their connections and their friendship
but now with covet you know and with the
limitations of going outside
i think video games have been playing uh
a a great role in making them feel
um that they're close to their friends
they're engaged and
and actually a couple of years ago i was
actually partnering with video games and
and had one of our brands
in video games so i've changed my mind
and i absolutely think it's a great
asset it has to be dosed
it can't be the whole day uh but i think
it's a it's a great asset so
renata it's great to see you continued
success thank you gary
next we welcome casey herbis the cmo of
rocket mortgage
who is driving new innovative strategies
leading a thirty three hundred person
in-house marketing agency in detroit
casey launched rocket mortgage's two
super bowl commercials which claimed the
top
two positions on usa today's ad meter
his leadership helped place rocket
mortgage into ad age's best places to
work
in in the 2021 list and he came from
24 years in automotive marketing most
recently for
fiat where he brought the brand to the
us welcome casey
case how are you good man good to see
you we need to get you to detroit here
soon
i'm ready i'm ready brother i'll go
anywhere i know
you know last time i saw you i think it
was the lions game when uh sam darnold
was dropping dimes on us back in the
good old days
that was uh his first career pass was
the interception that stadium was
rocking everybody was like throwing
garbage at me and then we luckily had
the last laugh in that day
case before we get into any i mean you
have so many great innovations
people are exploding on the chat loving
your super bowl ads
the innovation of your wardrobe is what
i'm passionate about
i said this to you in a private meeting
the other day i just love the way you
[ __ ] dress
talk to me about the creativity of the
way you dress do you think that
inspires i'm being dead serious now do
you think it inspires
creativity um i'll tell you a lot of
times it's
i don't know there's no strategy to me
it's just about you know establishing a
little bit of the personal brand and
bringing some of my personality
out um and for me it's just it helps
stifle and
bring creativity to the forefront like
you know i should have been wearing my
gary v
key swiss shoes today uh but i got some
easies on i love wearing easy's with a
suit and
you know for me it kind of like sets the
tone i mean we're so blessed to work in
such a dynamic
creative world whether you're on the
media account or you know uh the
business side of it and so to me it's
just it's
the ability to you know feel creative
and bring it out every single day
where i couldn't agree more a great
comment from first name last name
on youtube saying that little pink is
poppin i agree
um right to the crux of the question
for today's show uh where are you trying
to innovate in 2021
yeah and a great question gary i mean i
will tell you when it comes to
innovation
a lot of it starts at the very top and
that's culture
um you know you've had a chance to spend
time with us in detroit you know dan
gilbert
you know dan gilbert started this
company 35 years ago as just
him his brother a partner a little
mortgage company you know outside the
city
and now here we are 20 000 plus in
downtown detroit
and it starts with culture and dan 20
years ago as he started the company
realized
i need to have these foundational
principles that let us drive our
decision making
how we conduct or put ourselves inside
outside the office
i mean it is if you think about culture
i mean culture starts to build success
it frames expectations
it delivers creativity and so for us
we do not sit back i mean yeah we're
america's largest lender
but it is like i can tell you behind the
scenes is just thinking about
how are we going to continuously
innovate move faster than the speed
of the game and for us you know that
that i think you saw that this past
super bowl with our creative i mean you
know that a lot while brands may be back
in the summer like
should we be in the super bowl yes no
should we be serious should we like
we with our culture and being able like
let's go
if we fail we fail fast learn from those
lessons being able to innovate whether
it's business
product client service or creative is
like that's who we
are and it starts at the very beginning
the top with the culture and it
permeates its way
all the way through the organization and
even with our agency partners
who we may work with or media partners i
mean everybody's got to have a seat at
the table
when it comes to our business there are
no secrets i'd rather bring in an agency
partner or a media partner
early on and help us develop that
innovation and bring that idea in a
marketplace
that makes you know that can help
elevate itself on any specific platform
i don't know if it was renata or just
like your energy or like i don't know
where i'm at in my mind but i'm going to
ask the question that i want to ask
do you think your parents were
innovative that
set you up for success i i'm just i
don't i'm like
going very intuitive here right now i'm
sorry literally
let's go back to casey's childhood i
mean i'm yeah you kind of motivated me
right it's culture
i you know it's funny knowing dan maybe
it's where i am in my life or i'm like
man
there's gonna i'm gonna have to have
stewards of my companies as i continue
to grow
and i'm like listening to you i'm like
man i need to i need to have people like
this that continue it if i'm on to
you know buying reebok or starting an
nft company i'm being serious so i'm
just
genuinely curious innovating from
parenthood you're not
you and i are an age group where
parenting was going down a very specific
book
you know the way you're just cut the
charisma the kind of energy you bring
i'm just genuinely curious innovation at
the parent level anything you can tell
me any insight well listen
you know i grew up i grew up blue collar
kid dad was a firefighter mom
mom worked at a restaurant i was the
first kid in my extended family to be
blessed enough
uh to go to university the great
michigan state university and you know
getting to this business is just like
for me i've been doing this 28 years
and i enjoyed the first 24 in automotive
did a lot of amazing things there
but when i joined this organization four
years ago gary and again you know
uh you know you've spent time with us
like the it's just so infectious to be
in an
organization that fosters you know
innovation cult you know driving the
culture inside outside the walls i mean
to me it's just
i wish i found this organization 10 15
years ago i got a lot of miles left on
these tires
but it's just so exciting to see how
we're continuously iterating
and thinking about not just what's today
what's going to happen in the financial
wellness sector if you will
this year next year five years 10 years
down the road we're working towards that
let's talk about that because i think
this is where this could get interesting
you have out maneuvered your competition
over the last 35 years there's nothing
else to say about it
how significant are the conversations
and understanding of how powerful
the blockchain is going to be in
disrupting the mortgage industry are
those combos
you know you're in a funny spot when
you're the one disrupting
and there's an innovation looming that
has
incredible disruptive powers in its
bones how much is that a combo because
i think that's where a company like this
can get caught this is cliche
35 years you're kind of beating to the
punch the incumbents
meanwhile there's a complete platform
shift thing brewing
that may let a new thing happen i call
it put yourself out of business before
somebody does it for you
how real of a combo is that case yeah i
mean
obviously there's a lot of conversations
you know being america's largest lender
for us
it's you know there's an old adage too
is something when you're the lead dog
you know you know you don't want to
look behind your shoulder you gotta
unders understand what's right in front
of you
uh there's also an ism you don't
understand what our isms are here is
sometimes you gotta
ignore the noise so there's a lot of
things maybe disruptions in the
marketplace
you know what we're focused on is we'll
understand what those disruptions mean
might be how could they possibly affect
our business but for us it's
about carving our own path and destiny
and making sure that we are just
running down that road and and if things
happened to
you know last year think about the
disruption to all of our lives back
march and april
like we literally overnight had a pivot
on a dime and that was totally
reactionary and then once we made sure
our team members our clients were safe
how can the hell can we be proactive
so literally in five days gary we stood
up the largest uh the nation's largest
cova testing center downtown detroit
in five days working with the city
helping hospitals like
so for us it's about moving at the speed
of the game pivoting and just
going like react it's like think
communicate and then
execute super bowl is my favorite ad in
the world even though i'm
mostly obsessed with digital uh you had
a big one
how do you think about innovating big
two how do you think about innovating in
super bowl like what
what's too much innovation what's not
enough innovation what's the future of
super bowl spots from your perspective
any thoughts on that front yeah great
great question gary and we've seen it i
mean you know you and i sat
watching sunday there was what 57 58
brands
almost every brand now has a celebrity
in it which you know
maybe over time if we look at it it
wasn't as many but what i'm finding
really interesting is how many brands
use celebrity
and maybe they're there just for the
sake of being celebrity i mean our our
approach is utilizing the talent and
we've been so fortunate
you know in my four three super bowls
i've been a part of here
keegan michael key jason mamoa last year
and this year with the awesome amazing
tracy morgan a big
a big nick and uh jets guy uh or a
giants fan actually
yes be careful i'm getting again yeah
that's right but but uh
the uh we we we want to use our talent
to help us tell that frame story you
know the brand story
along the way they help deliver it and
they're not just there for that so
i think you'll start to see brands doing
more of that and then obviously it's a
second third fourth screen like
you know we had our war room we had 25
people safely placed in a large room
and another 100 behind the scenes
activating not only our two spots but
pre-daring and post
i mean just the amount of war gaming
that needs to take place
to pull off a super bowl campaign it
just continuously evolves
you know we weren't thinking about tick
tock as a platform last year now we are
how do we list you know like how do you
utilize those tick tocks the emerging
you know technologies and media
platforms to help extend amplify
uh you know the largest investment any
brand's gonna do
you know on a you know a one night uh
one night uh standpoint
case with the final seconds the favorite
innovation that struck you as a human
in the last year new platform new app
new anything
30 seconds on your favorite innovation
um well
good good question 30 seconds for me
biggest innovation last year's
i will tell you this is this is not
innovation but for me it's an innovation
that i've never worked from home in 25
years and now i have found myself
like i'm paperless so i used to make i
looked like you know i was a hoarder of
paper
now i'm paperless so for me it's like
it's sometimes when there's a crisis
and it creates develops an opportunity
and for us it was like
i found the crisis found the opportunity
and for me it's like i've innovated
myself and from work standpoint
leadership so
thanks for being on brother see you
buddy
next we welcome lisa joy rosner svp
brand and digital marketing who claimed
an entirely new role at oracle
focused all on content lisa joy is a
silicon vet
having worked in data and analytics her
entire career
she lives by her mantra tell me it can't
be done
and i'll do it birthing four children in
four years while launching two startups
welcome lisa joy thank you so much i'm
so excited to be here
lisa joe you're like a superhero two
companies four children four years
like i think i go at it that's
incredible it's great to have you here
well thank you you know it's funny
listening to that i was thinking about
yeah we had four kids in diapers and i
was in the middle of launching this this
big social media company
and we also had eight puppies at that
time
and here we are in the middle of the
apocalypse
and now not eight kids and diapers but
eight eight kids four kids
going through puberty and
and we got nine chickens
so it's it's really going at it and
instead of doing a startup
doing this just monumental
shift in a company like oracle let's go
to that you know
knowing a little bit about your
background um
coming into something so big
and then really focusing on you know
brand digital marketing
where how are you trying to innovate the
math how are you trying to innovate
the magic or the art that is required to
be a storyteller in 2021 because i'm
sure that's what you're balancing
well that that's an amazing question so
let me talk about the art first
please the art is the voice of the
customer
oracle historically has led with talking
about our products
instead of the amazing work that we do
for our customers
and so the magic has been we've surveyed
over
20 000 customers in 19 different
languages i've personally interviewed
i don't know many many many like at
least 25
different customers and we are taking
that voice the customer and infusing it
into everything we do so that's the
magic
the math listed excuse me for a second
so
from your standpoint on that us all who
are watching we're going to come
connect more with what you've enabled
more so than the information of the tool
that's
enabling it is that is that how you see
it
say that i am well if it's through the
voice of the customer
right the stories of the customer of
like the people
that are actually using these incredible
tools that is a more of a connection
point than utility nature the stories of
the people using the utility
more than utility right like the
carpenter's story
inherently is more interesting than the
hammer and the screwdriver
absolutely absolutely so you look at
someone like landlakes where
during the pandemic and having to
completely change their supply chain and
where
where with all this baking that we're
all doing they have to get more butter
to supermarkets faster so instead of
talking about
supply chain and erp we're talking about
that butter that's going into that apple
pie that you're baking right now
does that make sense so that's the
content and
the thing that i wanted to talk about
today which well i have mentioned is ai
so the thing that i'm really excited
about from an innovation perspective is
an ai
so to answer your question about the
math part of it
we are ai is incredibly sophisticated
and there's some things i i'd love to
talk about if we have time
but there's a whole new approach to
analytics
that that one of our guys cause cause
calls it um
augmented analytics so for for example
you can actually talk to the system and
say hey
tell me how much butter we're selling
tell me the stores where we're selling
more butter right or or tell me
tell me the stores that are buying the
most butter and then the ai can go and
say
well not only are they buying butter but
they're also buying sour cream
right it's it's that next true you know
and you know this because you're
grounded more in tech people talk about
ai
ml and things of that nature but when
you really look under the hood
these startups or things that nature
they're far from that what you just
described
is actual intelligence i asked this
question about
butter and stores they said that's cute
gary here's the information
but let me also tell you that a third of
those people pick up flowers at the
register what do you think about
that i'm like oh [ __ ] computer i think
that's crazy let's do this well so let's
talk about this a little bit more
because the ai
is no longer fake news so i have some
mind-blowing
stats for you we just did
this survey the the division that has
human resources products and
we surveyed consumer you know lots of
people are very depressed right now
and we asked them all these questions
around mental health
okay are you ready gary 82
of people who are dealing with mental
health issues right now during this
apocalypse
would rather talk to a robot than to
their boss
there's a lot of shitty bosses out there
lisa well you're right
you're right i mean that i mean like you
know talking about real innovation
if bosses started thinking that they
work for their employees instead of the
other way around
[ __ ] computers wouldn't be winning
this poll so i couldn't agree with you
more yeah but keep going
more but i just can't let that one go
because well it might you know so we
were talking with rihanna about about
technology so my kids don't have cell
phones
not terrible mean mother that i am but
the other day i heard my
kid i was like she sounds like she's
talking on the phone and she was
actually
sitting and talking to alexa they were
telling each other jokes
so she'd rather sit and talk to the
human than one of her siblings
and alexa is not even that smart our our
oracle ai is really really smart and so
what
why would people rather talk to a robot
well yes they have shitty bosses but
also
because of where ai is right now they're
learning the patterns they can have that
conversation and be
empathetic and not be burdened by having
a bad day
right and so what is that telling us
that's telling us that we are ready to
add conversations
to marketing so i have another really
interesting thing to tell you that is
really funny because you asked me about
the data side of it the data side of
course is going to be your crm
and the current state of crms we did
this other survey
66 of sales professionals would rather
clean their toilet than fill in their
their crm system right
first of all i love the fact that you're
making the questions romantic in real
life
that being said cleaning a toilet is
actually quite relaxing lisa joe i don't
know if you know that
i i'm not dead serious okay i feel that
way about laundry
because i feel like a huge sense of
accomplishment and like look how
perfectly folded everything is and
all the drawers are tidy toilet cleaning
not that much
not so much not that much i mean i will
clean the toilets but i do not
know the manual filling out is
as the oracle ai gets stronger and
stronger we're not going to have to do
that correctly you could just talk to it
okay and and as a sales leader you can
say tell me who
my top performing reps are what's the
probability that we're going to
hit our numbers this joy on that note
because you're doing it from a b b2b
front you referenced alexa which is more
of a b2c
obviously all the big tech companies are
working on this i'm just you know i
really value your opinion
your gut and this is hard this is a hard
question your gut
to when us humans are interacting with
an ai voice
consumer facing tool like you're
referring to where we're really doing
damage
right you and i are hanging out we're
like let's order some sushi and instead
of going to a phone
and going to an app which seems
revolutionary by 25 years ago
i'm gonna be like blank pic what company
you want or what name they call it
send me the best sushi currently in the
city uh and
and pick the things i want or things i
like or things like this or no
no no uni i'm a nuni guy so extra uni
how far away are we from that nirvana
that is obvious
what's your gut tell you on when that's
a real scenario
five years really that quickly you think
right even closer possibly it depends on
our listeners and how or how much of
early adopters they want to be
mm-hmm i think really you think you know
it's really that close so i i i'm sorry
interrupt
like you think i'm just going to keep
asking because you're going to know
better than i am
uh i'll just use alexa hey alexa or hey
oracle hey oracle
uh get me the best seat to the highest
ranking play in new york city
uh now you feel like go ahead yes
so i went and met with our development
team yes
like yesterday and we they showed me hey
alexa
find me a coffee shop that is not
starbucks
and alexis said here all the starbucks
hey
oracle find me the coffee shops that are
not starbucks
well here's the tullies and here's the
coffee people and here's your local
store
i was blown away to see that so it's
already like we have the capability
right now do do you oracle
have the consumer capability to make a
consumer product and market it and get
it adopted
is the question in that game no but we
can help our com
no we're a big company but we can help
our consumer
yep exactly exactly can i tell you one
more thing
real fast and i'm super excited i like
the way you're gonna love this no go go
for me as a marketer we're using ai in
something that's revolutionary
where normally sports marketing is
slapping your logo up on a stadium which
we also do
but we're going to be using rai and
sports
broadcast so real time an athlete's
about to make a whatever
you know a point and up is going to be a
little cloud that says what the
probability is that they're going to
make it that's cool
so really cool so that so we're not just
like you know
doing brand marketing with pictures
we're actually
like showing how our technology works
and that kind of storytelling is what
really fills me up this is joy thank you
so much
thank you for having me this was so much
fun
next we welcome adam braun new york
times best-selling author
speaker entrepreneur and founder of
pencils of promise
the award-winning non-profit that has
built more than 500 schools globally
adam was also co-founder and ceo of
mission u
a higher education startup named one of
fast companies 50 most innovative
companies
before being acquired by wework adam has
been featured as a speaker in the white
house
the united nations and the clinton
global initiative
welcome adam thank you for having me
adam hey gary how are you i'm great
i'm great how you doing i'm doing quite
well i i should disclose that i've been
a very very proud board member for
quite a long time and adore this human
being quite a bit so this may be a very
soft kind of sweet interview but i'll
try to get some juice out of it adama
what's what's how are you as a human
thinking about innovation in 2021 maybe
as
a parent as a friend as an operator
when i just throw that out to you where
do you go
yeah um i mean it's a couple different
threads for me right now
i think you know one of them is um
pencils of promise for those who aren't
familiar were you know global
uh what we think of as a four purpose
501 c 3 nonprofit
um organization that uh build schools um
provides access to quality teacher
training and really wrap around support
for students
uh across asia africa and central
america and um
you know as was mentioned at the start
now about more than 500 schools
around the world uh we serve about 100
000 students daily and
you know gary's been you know an
incredible incredible not just you know
friend
to the organization but when i asked him
to get involved he said adam if i'm
going to do this i'm going all in
and i'm uh and so he's been a a member
of our board of directors um and an
incredible one at that
and you know truthfully gary this this
whole uh last year has
kind of brought me back to the beginning
of when pencil of promise
was created because i founded the
organization
in october of 2008. it was
i believe maybe two or three weeks after
lehman brothers declared bankruptcy
and you know there's this feeling at the
time that the
kind of institutions that everyone
looked at with such reverence that that
were kind of untouchable
uh that suddenly not just one within
multiple
toppled and and as much as there was a
lot of
sadness and you know people were losing
jobs you and i were both in new york at
the time and
you know it was a really difficult
moment culturally
but in that kind of darkness there was
two things that that i observed that i'm
now seeing again
uh the the first is um just an explosion
of of innovation of willingness to try
new things of
of kind of you know dissipation of fear
that existed beforehand that people are
suddenly saying you know some i got
nothing to lose
and so i'm willing to try something and
then the second is
um i think in in hard moments um you
know
people gravitate towards the good and
they they seek out opportunities to be a
part of something that's a little bit
bigger than themselves that can
you know maybe focus a little bit more
on creating legacy
and and you know as i look at kind of
the rebound from 2020 now
hopefully enough swinging into 2021 um
i feel like i'm seeing that i feel like
you know there's just a willingness to
try new things
and ideally align those new things with
creation of good and
you know whether it's in my role as a
parent to young twins or
you know in my role as um executive
chairman at pence as a promise
uh i'm excited about the willingness to
try new things and and
our gala last year that you know you
were a huge
uh driver of how we not only um crafted
it
but then in the execution of it i think
was a perfect example of that
you know it's funny two of the people in
my life you know that i think of as most
thoughtful
on this exact show we started this show
today with will i
am and i think he's just quite
thoughtful in time i spent
i i think the same about you is there
from that thoughtfulness lens since you
both were on and it was just i was just
thinking about it
has this time being down at least not
moving physically
allowed you to think more and has that
led to
learning about more innovations it just
struck me
completely 100 i mean you know
you know this but um for those who
aren't familiar i normally live in the
new york area
and in you know consideration of the
fact that preschool was potentially
going to go remote again
the uncertainty of what you know the the
academic year looked like
uh i relocated uh with my wife and
little kids to the top of powder
mountain in utah
and right now behind me on this screen
is you know an expansive
series of mountains i'm at 9000 feet of
elevation and you know when
when you forcibly put yourself
in places like this whether it's
physically or or mentally
you just start you know one um being a
little bit more patient
in ways that that you probably weren't
historically at least that i wasn't and
what it leads to is
i find you know i feel like i'm thinking
bigger thoughts i'm looking at longer
time horizons you know
the the commitment to the next week is
still there but
my mind is also really thinking about
the commitment to the next decade
and you know i remember um one of our
board members previously the great ray
chambers
challenged me many years ago when i was
asking him you know how do i push this
organization forward how do we do great
work how do we impact more kids and he
said
you know adam if i was you i would look
at uh
you know your abilities your
relationships
uh where you want to focus your energy
but i would also think about where the
world is going to go in the next five
years and how can you align those two
things
to really intersect and that's how i'm
thinking about
all the different parts i mean you know
i i i
said this to some of the pencil promise
you know board members previously and
i'm
totally comfortable sharing it publicly
you know the world looked very different
in 2008 when the organization was
started and the goal was to build as
many schools as we could
and now i think a lot about not just how
do we push
um you know our our scale um
to be faster but how do we make it
smarter how do we you know
impact right this is something we talk
all the time impact impact impact right
exactly and you know if and by the way
by the way you're you know as executive
chair
your dna is still still in the thing
that you created
you're a different man i mean you know
as soon as you said that the world looks
so different you know in my own head
because i'm trying not to interrupt here
because people get mad but i only have
10 minutes i'm trying to get the things
back
i said to myself you're different
very very i mean i didn't have kids at
the time right i mean
you know the the difference between
rationally thinking about
what do i want for the well-being of a
child versus now as a parent
uh thinking about how do i want my kids
to experience education and then how do
i apply that
to the attainment of education for kids
around the world who might not have
access to it otherwise
it's just a totally different lens and
you know i i think
at the same time you know we've always
been very brand centric as an
organization
and i think the the success of our brand
has really been rooted in authenticity
more than anything else and that's
something i think you and i have always
really kind of um connected on
yeah let's have a little friendship chat
yeah
you knew the human outside the arena of
pop and you know and you know have you
picked up video games are you watching
more netflix like tech like clubhouse
tick-tock the innovation
lens of you my buddy yeah like if it's
just me and you right now catching up
i'm like hey
you know just doing my own research
because you know i love this [ __ ] like
what you've been hot on from an
innovation standpoint or what blew you
away or what's going on in this mountain
now do they like deliver hot cocoa in
one second
if you hit a button like what innovation
struck you in these last two minutes for
some fun
sure um so you know i was really uh
probably like you one of the kind of
earlier people that were fortunate to
get an invite on the clubhouse and i
spent some time on it
and then i thought ah this is just
taking me away from being present with
the people in front of me and
i kind of stepped away and i didn't use
it for months but uh i recently got
invited
into um a a room like a session that was
being run
and man i was blown away
by just the connective tissue that was
being experienced across
totally different parts of of a
sub-sector of an industry
old jam sessions that we used to do 100
that that
that has been a big part for me i think
another one is
um you know i feel like to some extent
i've like reconnected with the value of
text and
and whatsapp chains you know like before
they weren't as as
kind of um i don't know it was like more
one-on-one connection
um but just yeah i think the social life
like
everybody misses socialization so you
got your high school crew your
basketball career my last year my main
social
uh experience was a whatsapp chain from
my fantasy football league which is
college friends
and and so i think that's been a big one
and then at the same time i mean i
always had a mindfulness in meditation
practice but
um in the last year i've really been
able to lean into it and spend a lot
more time on it
um and you know there's a whole bunch of
apps out there but but i'll give a shout
out there's one called shine i have no
affiliation to it
um but um i discovered it through the
time
i didn't
um and then another one i just met uh
the entrepreneur on a chair lift uh the
other day it's called breath work
um and it's kind of like a modified
version of full meditation
i know
next we welcome mayor gupta chief
marketing and strategy officer of
gannett
usa today network mayor leads a team of
marketers
growth hackers and data scientists to
drive the company's transformation
from a news and media platform to a
digital content subscription marketplace
previously mayur has held top roles at
freshly
spotify kimberly clark and sapient nitro
and is a serial investor in a long list
of startups
if he wasn't leading the transformation
at gannett he would be playing cricket
for
india or tennis for the usa welcome by
your
mojo how are you man i'm great gary big
fan thanks for having me
yeah i'm so mad i wanted to say it first
i really admire you i we
haven't had a chance to jam but i'm i'm
hoping this is a starting point
so this this feels extra for me i
because i do think
i really respect from afar your points
of view uh
by your actions investments and things
that you've done
i'm dying to know what actually even
like both give me both
you at gannett which is such a classic
company i think that's cool you know
i've
long said i want to buy nostalgic brands
and reboot them to me the transformation
of something is more interesting than
starting something from fresh
actually let's stay there because i
wonder if that's like i just saw your
reaction so i wonder if that kind of
like
was attractive to you as well sir well
it was uh
scary and attractive to be very very
candid i sat on the board of the knight
for uh for almost two years that
gave me the insight into the value
system and the belief system of the
company and also
where the bodies were buried so i it
wasn't uh
it wasn't ambiguous to me but like you
said
i spent a big part of my career in very
growth stage startups have
seen them scale up and have been very
grateful and fortunate
this is an opportunity gary to work at
an organization
which has a 100 year old legacy and a
purpose and mission that could not be
stronger and could not be needed at a
more appropriate
time than right now where local
communities need
information and news that you can trust
but
uh many organizations haven't evolved as
fast as the world had changed so i felt
that
the real challenge for me personally
which is what made me jump
over was can i bring everything that i
have learned through the failures and
the mistakes i've made
to bring that rigor the disruption the
self-disruption
the pace uh removing the fear of failure
in a huge organization with almost 20
000 people
because that's magical with high risk
but if you pull it off in a
transformation from
a legacy media business that is obsessed
with
traffic and audience to a content
subscription business that is
obsessed with customer value that will
be a a fantastic experience and a lot to
learn
when did innovation hit your radar how
young
and what was it that hooked you into
technology
innovation not technology like it was
the first
i think people i want to make sure i
land this question it's not like you
grew up with this
oh you liked video games right away i'll
give you an example
when i saw nintendo after playing atari
the jump was so big that i couldn't wrap
my head around it i'm like oh
tech like things can happen like this in
my life because i was 10 or 11 at the
time i'm like
things will happen like this and then
obviously the internet was the next big
one i just couldn't even comprehend
for you when was the first time that
innovation
yeah so first of all
i grew up in india and uh when i was
growing up
uh unless you were really smart so i
didn't fall into that category
if you wanted a job you did computer
science so i did i became an engineer
did computer science got my job so i
spent
i i break my career apart in two phases
gary phase one
where i was a hammer i was writing code
i was an architect
then got into product development in the
mid 2000s but i was still
a hammer a good hammer and i was looking
for nails all around
the pivot for me where innovation even
the word made sense was in the second
half of my career when i finally left
um my alma mater almost which was safe
in nitro where i learned everything
and my foundation is still there uh but
when i joined kimberly clark was the
first time after 12 years
i kind of left the gym to get into a
tournament
that is when i finally understood that
look the solve was not technology
the soul was the application of
technology and data to change a human
behavior that prevented your growth
how many how many how many people do you
think missed that point
uh 9.9 out of 10. it's funny because
you just summed up why i think things
have worked for me
i've understood the human part and
stayed dangerous enough to understand
the tech part
yes but that was the commodity while all
my tech friends thought that
and i was like that was humans and
and i feel that there are so many shiny
disco balls that we all have whether it
is data or even
insight let alone technology the focus
for the world today even for our
children i know you have kids and i have
two daughters
it's all about not as much knowing
everything but it is how do you apply
when you know it because knowledge is
commodity
application is where creativity and data
and science and design kind of comes
together 100
um so what is the challenge in front of
you
what is like what is the real first
tangible practical thing that you're
like
i need to address this yes
see for us of course there is a list of
a lot of exciting
tech channels content all that stuff but
i think
what is most fundamental for me and the
organization
is that underlying mindset evolution and
shift
to to create a belief system
that that thinks that the only the only
way for us to win
is when you run faster than the
competition everything else is commodity
stay right there stay right there yeah
yeah coming from you
i know my audience i know how i
communicate i love this
you just articulated the value of speed
i really need you to say that again
because i know i have a mix of
youth entrepreneured i'm going to do it
for me or i want to leave my job or
get a new job or a lot of senior
marketers
the fact that you've said basically what
i've been living my whole life which is
the speed is binary
the variable because you'll get to the
answer of no quicker while people debate
if they can find yes
yes and that's melhany and i learned
that at spotify i learned that from the
founders party for daniel who
who firmly believed that even though at
that scale of spotify which was already
humming
well we still knew we went fast enough
and i know that
as a matter of fact he knew you when did
you come into spotify
how many years in in 2016. so we were
that was the ninth year at spotify
chinese and daniel and i know daniel a
little bit the reason he felt that
is i mean people come into vaynermedia
right now they're like this is so fast
and i'm like we're slow
as [ __ ] daniel knows that at year nine
you guys were
much much slower than what he felt in
the first four years
because most people are trying to
protect what they have
to think about what they don't because i
i feel and this is
our startup journey what i have my one
of my biggest lessons learned has been
the biggest barrier for companies to
move forward is their past success
because the levels that have got you
this far
may not and most most often will not be
the levels that will get you forward
a hundred literally i mean jesus now you
know
sometimes when you know usually this
happens in person it's happening right
here
you have those meetings where you
finally meet somebody that you from afar
you're like
there's a lot right i'm like i'm just
enjoying myself i could
i literally tell everybody the single
thing that is about to put you out of
business is the thing that got you
to where you are 100 yeah what
what what what can people do like help
everybody here in the last minute and a
half
as a person that works somewhere as an
entrepreneur as a key executive
since we're so aligned i just want to
hear your version on
okay let's say they just believe us
because they can see the conviction in
our eyes
yeah what do you do it is
contribute in creating an environment
that is safe to begin with right where
where people
feel that i'm not going to be judged
where they are
where you remove the fear of failure and
you know it's taken me many years and a
lot of mistakes
the only way you do that is not by
telling them hey you can fail and it
doesn't matter
it's by showing that you yourself is are
failing
and being huge on accountability
absolutely absolutely when you when
you're accountable to your losses not
just
when you're accountable yes it inspires
incredible safety
absolutely absolutely and that
single-handedly carry
is what i feel creates ultimately that
environment that we're
right and you got to create a culture
with trust and transparency where people
learn
how do you do that if the ultimate boss
isn't that human
well you well then you got to be art and
science
create proofs prove it take baby steps
right the challenge is the challenges
people think
on day one people think how do i solve
scale problem
the only way you solve scale is when you
don't solve for scale
correct you can't you can't boil the
ocean yes you can and that's the thing
you
to put points on you know incremental
steps
i'm so pissed you have to go and i have
to go andrew will beat me up so i
apologize by maria we've got to continue
this
love you man that was this was fantastic
next we welcome gregory constantine an
award-winning businessman
product developer and entrepreneur he is
co-founder
and ceo of air company using technology
and creativity to help decarbonize the
planet
the company is applying its technology
in a number of verticals including
spirits
fragrance and renewable fuels air
company has been awarded time magazine's
invention of the year
nasa's co2 challenge winner and many
others
welcome greg thank you appreciate it
gary i'm sorry that you're pissed you
have to leave that last one mate
it was good right yeah it was good
it really was sold for scale without
solving for scale
that's it man and guess what this one
i've been looking forward to because
this one's the one i'm gonna be the most
quiet because i have so much to learn
uh and i'm so intrigued and interested i
only want to get my core
question out besides the official
question which is
how is your hair so [ __ ] brilliant
[Laughter]
oh i got it i need this i need it craig
i need the details grandmother
shampoo grandmother's dna i need the
actual answer my man
greek and lebanese australians that
mediterranean vlad mate
it's good if i had your hair i would
dominate the world
take that beanie off let's see what
you're working with i got nothing
brother let's go it's going away over
the place
i'll say so let's go into it how are you
actually
let's do three minutes on what you you
all do because i think people are gonna
love it yeah
yeah yeah for sure we turn carbon
dioxide the most abundant greenhouse gas
on planet earth causing climate
change into products into products that
are hopefully
better than their predecessors so rather
than use the word kind of disruption we
always just talk about innovation how do
you go and create something better than
before
that isn't harmful to the planet it's
actually helpful to the planet
how did give me your journey on this you
the human yeah
yeah yeah for sure this is actually my
this is my first company
i met my business partner stafford um
who's our co-founder and cto in a bar
overseas
um we were on a leadership trip overseas
we met in a bar we were both working you
know in separate endeavors at that same
time
and we just became friends we became
really good friends and we kind of
really bonded over our
i guess our love for innovation um and
we really
um you know chose a path and not the
path of least resistance we chose the
path of pretty much
the hardest resistance in trying to
create something that hasn't been
created before and
trying to uh innovate in an industry
that wasn't necessarily
being spoken about at that period in
time um and and at the moment where
we're really focused on
you know taking co2 uh and turning it
into things that can be
helpful um so we've launched you know a
couple products in the interim one being
a
a vodka that that did win time magazines
eventually the year last year
and then we put out a sanitizer during
code uh
break down the vodka or the sanitizer so
people actually understand
how this works yeah we take
um carbon dioxide that's either in the
atmosphere or about to be admitted to
the atmosphere and we combine it with
hydrogen um that we create ourselves all
powered by renewable electricity
our facilities in brooklyn new york city
and when those two things combined
together
within our piece of technology the
reaction that's caused creates
ethanol which is a type of alcohol so
spirits like vodka as you know having
run a liquor store
uh are alcohol on water that's what
vodka is so the way that we make our
vodka
and we remove the pound of carbon
dioxide for every liter that we create
and because we're not making it from
fermentation you know from
corn or grains there's no impurities in
it uh
at all so it's it's really really ultra
pure so it's fantastic for consumption
as well
right what do naysayers you know i think
this when you're doing this kind of
innovation right
it always comes with naysayers what's
the naysayers point of view
and what's your rebuttal yeah the
naysayers point of view is it's not real
um you know how can two
30-something-year-old you know folks do
this if people have tried over
so many years of time as well has it
been that big of a challenge
scientifically
yeah we're definitely standing on the
shoulders of giants for sure and people
who have tried
uh but that's really just a testament to
to stafford whose brilliance in the
science
and then i think our amazing team and
their brilliance in making people
think that it's beautiful and making
people know that it's you know it's sexy
and the product is great because when
you're trying to do something new
and quite unquote sustainable um you
really want the product to speak for
itself first as well
but um what was the most difficult part
of this innovation obviously i know
stafford is the cto
but obviously as a co-founder and ceo
you're clearly aware
even if you weren't like fully fully
touching it what was the big
what was the most difficult part or not
even the science
what about that you know that beer
you're having seven months in
where it's like really not moving maybe
it was an emotional or mental hurdle
thoughts yeah um one of the trickiest
ones is actually
you know having people understand what
you do and this comes down to what
you're talking about in terms of
marketing right it's like how do you
take
what's typically known as a really
really heavy piece of technology in
science and make it palatable for people
to understand
we're able to make this technology
palatable by creating a product and
showcasing that product
but there are so many amazing
technologies out there in the world that
don't see the light of day
because the technologist isn't being
able to be met with
you know the marketing of the business
and is that why you both felt that way
about each other you
you two as founders represented one and
the other yeah it's the it's the yin
yang for sure you know
completely you know opposite skill sets
that when you bring them together
they're like that perfect kind of kind
of marriage as well so yeah we really
think that that's that's why it works
well together and hopefully
let's talk about speed we talked about
speed in the last one hand sanitizer
the world does its thing how quickly
i mean i could see it from a mile away
the story already which is why i think
i'm going down that path
how quickly from oh [ __ ] there's a
global pandemic to
in market or in r d tell me through that
story because i think that will resonate
with a lot of people
yeah for sure so we were the first
company in the us to announce
as the switch to sanitizer before
everyone did stafford and i were you
know we're together and we just
saw the way that the world was
progressing and we saw it looking hey we
really think that things are going to
get progressively worse how can we help
what's the thing that we can do right we
know that we can make alcohol that can
help
so let's go out and do it and you know
granted we're making it on small scales
but we're still able to go out and pivot
the business really quickly
but again it's having the right team to
be able to do so
to be able to flip that switch straight
away and go from making vodka to making
sanitizer get the packaging
get it out the door and be able to help
people so speed is absolutely imperative
three rules of innovation first best and
only you've got to be all three at one
period in time you might go down but
speed is fully a part of that
first best and only you can be first you
control that narrative
uh best is often subjective and takes
time training
right and only probably goes away very
quickly how do you
deal when i think a lot of people here
struggle with that last part
so i'm a big fan of first
i i i want to be best but i know that's
that movie has to play out where i think
i've been able to succeed and what i
admire in others that
can succeed is not being crippled by
when i'm not the only
i've watched so many people get upset
as if they have the rights to the idea
in the world
when others come on board thoughts from
your perspective
of innovating the mindset of not
dwelling when bigger
maybe you perceive better newer many
competitors come into an innovation
thoughts on that right because i think
that's uh
i'd love to get your thoughts on that
sure competition is healthy you should
always look at that as a positive right
if someone else is trying to do what
you're trying to do
you've done it and and they've seen it
and now they think it's you know so you
look at it as a great way and on top of
that
you'll understand that you know everyone
is going to push everyone else forward
as well right
we always say that you know we're trying
to do something in the hope that other
people try to do either the same thing
or try to do things around it because
for what we're trying to do
from a climate and sustainability
environmental point of view we can't do
it alone
um so so so we love it right and we
think competition is is great and
it's going to move the world forward
final thoughts on innovation while i got
you for a minute yeah i think um you
know the the biggest thing for us this
year is is trying to make sustainability
sexy right it's trying to make it
trying to make it cool right you know
for whom greg because i think you're
dominating that that story is dominating
under 30. are you referring to above
that
or or are you trying to put the mail
it's you want to
make that cool a little more sustainable
under 32 because
there's real surface you know i spent a
lot of time with the kids
as they say and after the opening line
of like yay
they don't realize the hypocrisy and
their actions day to day so is it
is it deepening education where there's
openness and is there education not even
creating the openness above that
yeah we need we need corporate you know
corporate on your side as well because
that's what's really going to help push
the needle forward the education is
there and it's going to continue to be
there
and companies like this will continue to
crop up but if we can see it from the
top down as well
that's where real change is going to
happen and it needs to happen as well
i love it thank you so much for your
efforts appreciate it guys
last but not least we welcome carla
hassan chief marketing officer of city
carla oversees city's branding and
sponsorships global consumer banking
marketing
and its institutional client groups
marketing and sponsorships
previously carla had held c-suite roles
at toys r us
pepsico the kellogg company and more
carla serves on the advisory board of
the a
a's hashtag see her initiative and was
named an ad age
woman to watch welcome carla
hi it's so nice to be here man to
hearing that about me i think that just
means i'm old
more than anything else although harlow
like we're such friends that i get to
hang out with you with different
lighting and like you really
you really brought it today look at this
listen come on
i'm live are you kidding me you've seen
me at my worst gary
which is my favorite because you know
maybe first of all i love all the
natural stuff and second of all i think
you're the best and
you know i love you and your husband
your daughter big big fan
um of you the human first second third
fourth number five the marketer and so
let's focus on the marker side let's do
it
what are you trying to innovate oh you
know gary i've been thinking about this
word it is so big it's so big there's so
many
so many ways in to this conversation um
i i want to you i want to go to two
places
the first is digital innovation i can't
be
the have the role that i am at the at
the firm that i work at
and not talk about digital innovation
and it's really interesting
you know a small small story um when
covid first hit
it was we had so many consumers that
have
never actually deposited a check on
their phone
right and you know now they're afraid
right now they're afraid and they're
like i can't go into a bank or the bank
is closed i can't do it and so
they have no choice they've they've got
to do it once they
once they figured out that they could do
that and it was a seamless transaction
and that they trusted that their money
actually was in their account
there's just no going back right there's
no going back
and so the pace once you see it you
can't
see it you cannot see it and actually
once you do it you can't undo it right
like
literally once you experience that and
you're like wait a minute the money's
there
just like they said it was gonna be why
would i actually ever go back into a
retail location like literally why would
i ever walk there
particularly now and that i think that
little story
is just a microcosm of everything we're
seeing right and so from our perspective
it is so important to not just kind of
say oh yeah digital innovation is is
important for us but to actually live it
and so it what it's doing is it's
actually creating these
really unlikely partnerships so google
you know historically we might have seen
as a competitor right like tech is a
competitor particularly when you're
you know a financial services
organization but we recently announced a
partnership with them
because we felt like we just had to lean
in and so
from an innovation perspective
particularly on the digital side what
it's doing is it's bringing their
um their best-in-class user experience
if you will and their technology
and our best-in-class know-how on
banking
it's bringing them together and now
we're able to access an entire group of
people
that we never ever ever would have been
able to access if it was city going out
to them and saying
hey open a bank account right like or
open a savings account or
i mean it just so it really puts the the
power of the two together so
for for me digital innovation has been
really leaning into the most
unlikely of people and then also of
partners and then also thinking about
like
what are the major behaviors that are
changing and
never going back and how can we get at
that as fast as possible so
i would say that that's the that's the
first part and the second is innovation
and thinking
i think you know i've heard you know
greg a fellow lebanese you talked about
his hair you didn't talk about mine gary
but um
it's all giving you such compliments up
front come on what do you want
i'm totally kidding i'm totally kidding
but but it's not just about the
technical know-how i think when we think
about innovation
we have got to start thinking about how
do we think about innovative thinking
how do we think about
flexibility and agility and taking
chances for crying out loud and by the
way
in my world hard to do right because we
are a really in a regulated environment
and and do you think i'm sorry to
interrupt
do you believe that the blockchain
defy thing is gonna force you know
that's gonna be such a big combo
that do you think that in a weird i mean
that's that's that's for another day
right right do you believe that because
that's gonna be in the air
that it might give you as a marketer
more room
because now all of a sudden what they
might have seen as crazy
well that's minor compared to what's
going on over here do you feel like
yeah i kind of see it we're already
seeing it we're already seeing it gary
and it's not even just from again
like innovation like what you're talking
about in whether it's platforms or
systems or even the way that money's
moved around whatever
but it's also in what we're seeing in
communities it's all of it and so how do
we
really take some chances get a little
braver
in the way that we're thinking
experiment a little bit more which again
is hard it's hard paint a picture for
everybody what is what would be
considered something
experimental in from your point of view
in your seat
okay let me let me give you an example
um
yeah i'll give you an example of
something that we we that we just lived
um actually uh
with racial equity um we had
developed something that you know from a
campaign perspective or even like how
we're talking about it is
would just be uh i would say for some
people controversial
right so we we took a stand on something
we created some work
and it wasn't without its controversy uh
internally um not because we didn't have
the same values that we were talking
about but because people are like well
you know using this kind of language or
making these kind of sounds like
you know we've got constituents from
both sides
right you got to be careful and so i i
thought okay but we got to push this
because it's the right thing to do
and so we experimented in a controlled
environment
we're able to see like if we put this
message out what are people going to say
and so we did that we we put it out and
we got
great feedback we got some naysayers
there's no doubt about it but we got
really good feedback and then we're
comfortable enough to say all right now
how do we take it
and really explode it on a broader level
i think things like that and i've heard
a couple folks already talk about it
this notion of like
you've got to just try to do things
incrementally don't try to boil the
ocean because you've got a whole bunch
of naysayers
around you that you're not going to be
able to convince if you try to convince
them with the really big thing
so go you know do do is that is that
something that everybody who's listening
now
even if they have you know even if
they're not the boss of the boss of the
boss
do you think that general thesis of like
that incremental
even like as a conversation like i i
actually have a very important question
i think can help a lot of people
which is what i'm focused on right now
when i do these kind of things
do you believe that you are in this spot
in your career
because you were willing to politely or
politically correctly
communicate when you didn't agree with
what the senior things were going on i'm
actually wondering
yeah i think people are 100 gary 100
and i do think no matter who you are no
matter what level you are in an
organization
this is actually interesting right to
correlate with innovation because
we all talk about innovation as like the
product or the
platform or whatever we miss the
innovation in
thinking we miss the innovation and how
you talk to somebody there is a game in
that like there is a hustle
in that right how do you talk to people
differently how do you get your point
across how do you
put yourself in somebody else's shoes to
know that they're looking at a very
different kpi than you are
so how do you in your head on the spot
think about
how to talk to them differently and so i
think by the way
that my team uses it on me all the time
right you can
see it they use it on me all the time i
can see it coming and i actually
love it i love it by the way i always
look this way and i'm like i know what
you're doing and i love that you're
doing that so i'm going to reward that
oh i know what you're doing i don't like
that
i'm not going to reward that's right
that's right that's exactly right and
you know it's interesting to your point
about like
you know i'm in a certain position in my
career where i look on that i apologize
carla because i just
try to think of all two hours what value
we can bring for everybody who's been
here the whole time
do you then say what we just said here
that maybe innovation of taking
people realizing that eq not iq
like do you feel like the innovation of
the conversation around emotional
intelligence as leaders
needs to be a conversation period to
even begin to do the tangible part
100 and you know what you know we talk
about it today as empathy
right like you talk about it a lot too
we all talk about it as empathy and it's
such a what used to be an under
leveraged word and under appreciated
word and now everyone's trying to figure
out what the hell it means right
but the reality is it's in its simplest
form is put yourself in someone else's
shoes
know where they're coming from and then
you can solve problems
for them and with them in some cases
without even letting them know that it
was your idea
that to me to your point the eq of that
and the innovation
of like the thinking is equally as
important as
yes there is all kinds of stuff
happening from a product standpoint that
we've got to stay in touch with that
we've got to stay on top of
that's making us braver that's making us
more courageous and more innovative
faster but that part of it the eq part
of it
is so underrated and people don't think
about it enough and i
i think using that more and more that
muscle more and more
helps you get to the product part helps
you get to the ultimate goal that you
that you talked about
i love you i know it goes so fast thank
you i know
thank you andrea take us home all right
thanks gary and thanks everybody for
joining us
we've got another show coming up march
18th from
12 to 2 p.m eastern time and our central
question is going to be
how are you growing your customers into
fans in 2021
marketing for the now let's keep the
conversation going check out our past
recordings
and info on marketing for the now on
vaynerx.com and we'd love to hear from
you
thank you all of you for two hours it
was a real marathon i love all of you
thank you for all the comments great
chatter
hit me up on twitter with your feedback
marketing for the now i'll look at it
right now in between meetings
love you see i love you sia thank you
andrea and team jordy summer all the
greatness behind this show
bye have a great weekend everybody